the Pet Sematary remake unleashes a new
twist on supernatural horrors of Stephen
King spine-chilling novel yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers I'm John and in this video
I'm breaking down everything you need to
know about the shocking ending to the
new Pat Summitt tree including the true
nature of the demonic force in the movie
and the crucial changes from the
original story Plus keep watching to the
end for some bonus Stephen King Easter
eggs you might have missed spoilers
ahead so take care if you haven't seen
the movie yet the real antagonist at the
heart of the Pet Sematary story is the
Wendigo demon after Jordan Lewis find
Ali's beloved cat Church dead by the
side of the road they take it to the pet
cemetery for burial as they go to bury
the dead pet judge feels the pull of the
wendi-go spirit so instead he leads
Lewis over a barrier of sticks through
the woods and a swamp to an ancient
Mi'kmaq burial ground Jude then tells
Lewis to bury Church in this creepy
place that's full of whispering voices a
reanimated Church then appears at the
family house the next day though he's
much dirtier and meaner confused
Lewis visits jerd to demand an
explanation and Jed tells him about the
stories he's heard about the Wendigo a
malevolent demon feared by Native
American tribes in the northern regions
of the US and Canada the signs carved
into the trees in the woods on the way
to the burial ground which Lewis also
sees in the book at Jones house a
warnings left by the Mi'kmaq people
before they fled the area they also
built a deadfall as a wall or barrier to
stop people going into the cursed area
the ground beyond that barrier was
soured or cursed by the Wendigo meaning
that if a person or animal is buried in
the Olmec mat graveyard their reanimated
and end up possessed by the spirit of
the evil demon
for example even after Lewis realizes
the danger the resurrected Church poses
to his family and takes the possessed
cat far away the power of the Wendigo
inside Church is too strong and the cat
makes his way back to the family home
deliberately luring Ali into the road in
front of a speeding truck and jumping
out of the way to safety just before it
crashes into her the change in le is
even more noticeable initially after she
returns from the dead she's unsure where
she is but quickly understands
she's changed and she says to Lewis I'm
dead aren't I she also tells him that
she can hear the woods inside her
another indication that the wendigo
spirit has invaded and occupied her body
the demon also gives her an unnatural
physical strength that a nine year old
girl would be unlikely to possess such
as being able to drag her mother's body
all the way to the burial ground by
herself and when she fights her father
he finds it extremely difficult to
overpower her on top of that the
wendi-go can manipulate Ellie's body to
communicate and taunt the victim she's
about to kill when she attacks jerd
Ellie tells him how she saw his dead
wife Norma burning in hell and then the
Wendigo even transforms Ellie's body and
voice momentarily into Norma the
possessed Ellie does the same with her
mother Rachel first she blames her
mother for leaving her to die in the
road and then accuses her of having done
the same with her sister Zelda like Jett
he refuses to believe he's seeing the
real Norma Rachel tells Ally you're not
my daughter to which the now possessed
Ally replies then go be with her at
which point she stabs Rachel once more
there's an interesting similarity
between how the Wendigo exerts an evil
influence on people in Pet Sematary and
how Pennywise influences people to
commit terrible deeds and ears on top of
that there's a deliberate Easter Egg to
Stephen King's it with a road sign for
dairy in the scene where Rachel engages
stuck in a traffic jam as they try to
get back to Ludlow dairy is of course
the town in Maine where it takes place
and where Pennywise shows up every 27
years in contrast to it though where the
losers Club is able to band together to
defeat the evil spirit Pet Sematary has
a much darker ending in fact the 2019
remake goes further perhaps in the 1989
movie or the original novel in terms of
how many of the Creed family are killed
by the Wendigo in this version Ellie is
first killed by the truck Ellie then
kills her mother and resurrects her and
then as Lewis fights with Ellie the
reanimated Rachel comes out of nowhere
and mortally Spears Lewis through the
back after they drag his body off to the
Mi'kmaq burial ground we cut to a
chilling final scene of gage helplessly
waiting in the family car outside their
home Lewis Ellie and Rachel then appear
walking towards the car and Church jumps
menacingly interview
and as the screen cuts to black there's
a horrifying sound of the car doors
unlocking if you have any doubt about
whether gage survived there's actually a
clue in the opening scene of the movie
which heavily implies that he didn't the
scene shows the aftermath after the car
door was unlocked the doors been opened
and there are a couple of bloody
handprints on the window plus some blood
inside the door
it seems pretty likely then that the
possessed bodies of the crude family
will have killed gage and dragged him
off to bury and resurrect him providing
the evil Wendigo demon with yet another
corpse to inhabit however in the
original story it's just gage and Rachel
who were killed and they're both buried
by Lewis and resurrected and in the 1989
movie Rachel also kills Lewis after she
returns there's also a couple of other
major characters we need to talk about
first of all the Zelda Rachel sister who
has a terrifying part to play in the
remake and gets more screen time than in
the 1989 movie we learn in the film that
Zelda suffered from spinal meningitis
and is particularly scary scene where we
see just how badly she traumatized
Rachel Rachel he was left alone by her
parents to care for her sick sister used
a dumbwaiter to send up food to Zelda
but after the food got stuck Zelda died
in a horrific mangled mess when she fell
into the dumbwaiter and after Rachel and
her family moved to Ludlow it feels like
the spirit of the wendi-go that stalks
the land surrounding their new house
plays a part in soma nning the terrible
recurring visions of Zelda that Rachel
begins to suffer after the resurrected
Church returns to the house and starts
acting maliciously for example by
scratching Ellie for the first time not
only does Lewis hear a terrible groaning
sound from the basement with a warning
that the destruction of all he loves is
very near but Rachel starts to hear
terrible thumping noises from the roof
and inside the walls which culminate in
a petrifying vision of her dead sister
appearing inside the bathroom cabinet in
a similar way to how Zelda died inside
the dumbwaiter years ago
Rachel's case shows us again how the
Wendigo is able to use the grief shame
and sense of regret someone may suffer
after a terrible tragedy to manipulate
its victims psychologically and
eventually caused their downfall we also
need to talk about Victor Pascal who
plays a small but important part as a
voice he repeatedly warns Lewis again
it's the dangers of crossing the
deadfall he also tries to warn Lewis
against taking the dead Ellie up to the
burial ground though of course Lewis
ignores him and Pascale also warns gage
and Rachel that Lewis is in danger now
some people have theorized that Pascale
may not be acting so benevolently in pet
cemetery because you could argue that he
not only draws lewis's attention to the
deadfall but he also leads Rachel engage
back to Ludlow placing them in danger so
that they eventually become possessed by
the Wendigo however if we take Pascale
at face value as a caution and remember
that it was actually Jud who took Lewis
over the threshold I think that pass cow
is a character that serves to draw our
attention to the folly of ignoring the
warnings in front of us Pet Sematary
also warns us of the dangers of not
learning how to deal with grief and
tragedy appropriately for instance after
Lewis discovers Church has died Rachel
who's never been able to get over the
death of her sister Austin Lewis to tell
Ellie that her cat ran away
basically Rachel asked him to say
anything except that the cat died
likewise after Ellie dies Lewis can't
accept her death or his feelings of
guilt and regret insisting on staying in
Ludlow after both Ellie and Rachel asked
to move back to Boston so he
deliberately makes an excuse to stay
behind when Rachel engaged go to stay
with her family and he also drugs Jud so
he doesn't stop him from digging up the
dead Ellie and taking her to be
resurrected Jud who also didn't want to
see Ellie sad at the loss of Church was
the original instigator of course in
taking the dead cat to be resurrected
all of these terrible decisions show the
folly of not facing up to reality and
instead turning to superstition or
toying with supernatural forces we don't
understand I've already touched on a few
Pet Sematary book a movie Easter eggs
but there's some other interesting ones
you might have missed Ellie refers to
herself as Allie the great and terrible
both before she becomes possessed and
afterwards the nickname isn't just a
neat little bit of foreshadowing of her
terrible fate it's also an easter egg to
book Zelda who had a picture on her wall
of all the great and terrible which
smash when she died in King's novel as
the great and terrible becomes a theme
associated with an unnatural and evil
death and so of course it's especially
fitting that it's a title that Elias use
before she's taken over by the wicked
wendi-go spirit
an easter egg that flashes by pretty
quickly as when the truck driver who
accidentally kills Ali gets distracted
by a phone call from Sheena just before
the accident Sheena is a punk rocker is
the song by The Ramones that the truck
driver from the 1989 movie was playing
in his vehicle during the accident that
killed gage in fact the decision of the
filmmakers of this remake to change the
child killed and the accident did upset
some King purists you prefer the idea of
the youngest child becoming corrupted by
the wendigo and being turned into a
murderous infant for this movie though I
think it turned out to be a great change
and twist
Jesse Lawrence who plays Ali in the new
movie delivered a fantastic performance
as both the sweet-natured le before her
death and the angry murderously
possessed Ali after her resurrection
having the older child come back from
the dead also allowed her to interact
with her family in a way that just
wouldn't have been possible or realistic
with a toddler
and if you wondering whether there's
likely to be a sequel that follows on
from these events while the directors
have said they're much more interested
in a possible prequel story in an
interview with consequence of sound
producer Lorenzo de Bono Ventura said
that if there's anything here there's a
prequel if you look at the book we
didn't cover all that stuff that happens
before the Creed family moves in as he
says there are stories from kings
original book which weren't included in
this adaptation but which were included
in the 1989 movie such as how one of the
town's deceased World War two veterans
Timmy Bateman was resurrected after his
body was sent back to the town from the
war there was a tiny Easter Egg to this
in the new movie by renews paper
headline that flashes by very quickly
another area that could be explored in a
prequel is a jump further back in time
to when the Native Americans were still
in the area around Ludlow this remake
deliberately pointed out that the entire
plot of land that the Creed's
owned extended back to the pet cemetery
and beyond the barrier and when Lewis
was reading about the Wendigo in Judds
house there was a newspaper headline
that read Indian land claims still
unsettled a prequel could investigate
what part the Wendigo might have played
in any conflict over land between Native
American tribes and those who settled
the town of Ludlow now if you've seen
both movies which did you prefer tapping
the top right to vote and then you'll be
able to see the results and leave any
thoughts you have about the movie in the
comment
below if you enjoy deep dives like this
into your favorite horror films
subscribe and hit the bell to get all my
new videos tapleft but all the clues and
easter eggs you might have missed in
Jordan peels us or tap right for another
video you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time you pick
a movie lovers